[Musique]
l'aventuré pmp en amont lol
confiante et tnt en a en un mot c'est
amitié amour famille famille formidable
je t'aime d'un amour inaltérable mais
c'est mon fils le team au pouce et vous
offre une maison tu vas vite à jean et
hop à la maison et tu va préparer les
meilleurs vos bottes magiques
[Musique]
happy birthday cpmb joyeux anniversaire
la plus folle et missions du parc
[Applaudissements]
joyeux anniversaire et puis pourvu que
ça dure encore longtemps de temps en
temps nos 1000 2000 3000 est bien sur la
civière
[Musique]
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
aura marqué la télévision donc joyeux
anniversaire tekken péchabou à l'eau à
tous d'accord avec nous